you can increase your odds of success
two to three x just by having a specific
plan
i love when people tell me i can't i
love when it doesn't work for other
people i love to find
the things that are working and compound
the things that are working and stop
doing the things that you're not
that don't work what are you doing with
friends that don't have any fresh
thoughts
i mean aren't you tired of being around
people that
basically nothing's changing in their
life want to be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn a few simple
rules to change your bad habits in just
a few days
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a plan with james clear
you can increase your odds of success
2-3 x just by having a specific plan
and this is the insight many people
think that they lack motivation when
what they really lack is clarity
they think that they need to get more
motivated that they need willpower
in order to execute on a habit if i just
felt like writing if i just felt like
meditating i felt like working out then
i would do it
but in fact they don't have a plan for
it so they wake up each day
thinking i wonder if i'll feel motivated
to write today i wonder if i'll feel
motivated to work out today
but instead you can take the decision
making out of it by explicitly stating
when
where and how you want to implement the
habit so
here's how i did this with my writing
habit i decided that on november 12 2012
which was a monday if you check
um that was going to be the first day
that i published an article and i was
going to publish every monday and every
thursday that was my implementation
intention that was my specific plan
didn't matter how good or how bad it was
it didn't matter how long or how short
it was it didn't matter how i felt about
it if all i could do
was write three good sentences that day
then that was getting published
but i did that and i did it for three
years and that was how the site grew
it was just that core habit that drove
the growth
so you need to give your goals a time
and a place to live in the world right
give them space on your calendar
now it sounds easy to say let's just
start a plan let's you know write down
exactly what you should do and then
maybe you'll follow through on it but of
course we all know that there are
challenges that arise it's not quite
that easy
so here's a little strategy that i like
to use to make sure you can come up with
a better plan of action
and it's called a failure pre-mortem so
the way that it works is you think about
the habit the project the goal whatever
the most important thing is that you
want to work on
and i want you to imagine fast forward
six months from now you failed
and then tell the story of why you
failed what happened what challenges did
you encounter what was it that took you
off
course um when i do this with businesses
sometimes we call it the kill the
company exercise because everybody just
sits around thinks about ways to kill
the company in the next six months
and once you have all that stuff laid
out on the table in front of you
you can start to make better choices
about how to develop a plan you can
start to have if then plan so not only
do i want to exercise for 20 minutes on
monday at 5 p.m
but also if i do not exercise because i
have to take my kid to practice or
whatever
then tuesday morning at 7 a.m i will go
in right you can have ways to
adjust for these challenges rule number
two compound things that work
with dean graziosi when the economy
changes
when the the company's not working when
you tried the marketing it doesn't
it doesn't produce sales when you try to
get your friends to invest in you you
try to get the first
real estate deal and it doesn't work
what most people do
is continue to do the same over and over
and over again expecting a different
result isn't that the definition of
insanity
so because i had more passion probably
than anyone there
because i had a desire and a feeling it
reminded me of my grandpa being a kid
what i started to do i want you to think
about this i
started to recognize what was
working and what didn't remember we had
the same fishing hole
we had the same stream same fish that
were in that
in that stream same rods same bait
but what i started to realize is that
by hole three or four nobody was really
catching anything and it was like ah
they're not biting
but i'm like no there's got to be
something different so
i started to realize that when i walked
up
to the fishing hole even though the sun
reflected and i really couldn't see the
fish sometimes i could sometimes i
couldn't
they could see me because when i had the
right glasses on at the right angle
and i walked up i could see the fish
scatter i was like
wow i look down in a big pool and
there's big trout in there like this
they see me and they take off
i'm like wow trout are supposed to be
the hardest fish to catch they could see
me
what if they didn't see me so i started
learning that so i started finding ways
to hide
i started crawling up to the hole i
started standing behind trees
i started using the fly rod way far back
and landing it before they saw me
i also realized that when the trap when
the stream was coming if there was a
rock
or a log and the water would say there's
a rock
and it would come down and the water
would go around and circle
i could see other bugs and stuff
circulating there i'm like what a
perfect spot for a trout
but if you cast right on it while
they're looking at you you can't see
them
nothing but i watched guys cast there
but what i was doing is going way back
and casting upstream
and letting my fly float around the rock
boom i'd get a hit right so i start so
think about that
in business is it like this trout
fishing
so many people will try something tried
the facebook ad tried the business
tried to call on a real estate deal
tried amazon
and it's not working and so many times
we'll just do the same thing over and
over
my buddies because they didn't care
about it some of them some of them did
so
my buddies some of them didn't care they
were just doing the same thing over and
over nothing go to the next hole
nothing fish aren't biting i refused to
believe that the fish weren't biting
i'm just telling you it doesn't make me
any better i had desire passion and a
goal and i'm competitive
so i had a desire to learn do you see
the difference of just saying i've tried
it it's not working compared to a desire
and a passion i was obsessing i did not
believe the fish weren't biting even one
of the guides go
wow it's a flat day today must have must
be too warm today they're staying low
they're not feeding
i would not believe that just like when
people tell me
that you can't sell books online anymore
and i've sold over 350
000 of millionaire success habits i had
a desire i had a passion i had a goal
i'm competitive
i love when people tell me i can't i
love when it doesn't work for other
people i love to find
the things that are working and compound
the things that are working and stop
doing the things that you're not
that don't work are you doing that in
your life
with your relationship with your
business with your company are you
compounding the things that work and are
you diminishing the things that don't or
are you just doing the same thing over
and over again in a hypnotic rhythm
waiting for one day where it magically
works in most cases it won't
so when the economy changes if you keep
doing the same thing that's the
companies that go out
it worked on the way up and you keep
doing the same thing on the way down
it's not going to be
but when you constantly are testing
tweaking
trying putting the hook out there
waiting for it to come back
all of a sudden you start learning you
start growing
you start figuring out what's working so
what's up man it's good to see you i i
see you
all over the place i see you hustling i
see your impact in lives doing amazing
stuff on youtube
i want to share whatever works for you
know you're following my following today
but i want to share dude your book built
to serve
you are built to serve there's a
difference when
you know this is i've been an
entrepreneur for entrepreneur for over
30 years i've been in the self-education
industry for 24.
can't even seem it doesn't even seem
possible but there's a lot of people
that
when you kind of meet your heroes or you
meet the people behind the book
a habits book a built to serve book a
time management it's like you beat you
meet the guy with the time management
book and he's late getting on stage and
stressed out of his mind in the green
room
like there's no congruency is what i
want to say and before we chat today i
just want to honor you and give you
congruency this
what you wrote in this book is really
who you are man you are built to serve
you reach out to my team all the time
and
want to help with youtube and tell us
what we're doing wrong and it's not
you're not doing it because of
finances you're not doing it because
you're trying to get an edge you're
doing it just because
this is who you are man so i love seeing
you out there i love seeing you grow i
love seeing the impact you're making
cool man appreciate it i'm still working
on accepting compliments so
um i'll just say thank you oh then i'm
gonna keep doing it through this entire
thing to make you feel uncomfortable
oh great classic dean all right cool
well you know what also in that story um
you know you've been really helpful in
getting that book out i remember when i
came to puerto rico
and uh was trying to get feedback on
pre-launch
you won brendan richard took time
backstage
while you're doing your big event people
paid all this money to come there and
you took time
over lunch for 40 minutes to do a deep
dive
on my strategy um and just super
grateful that you guys did that and
you hooked me up with your warehouse and
you know a whole bunch of things that
dean's a big reason why the book is has
uh uh
just a little piece man just what's up
everybody i see the highs so listen
um appreciate everybody i see all the
cool comments coming in so how can we
deliver some value today how do we help
out besides
um i do gotta plug this like if you
didn't check out
uh evan's built to serve you should
check it out um the truth is
i'm not all the way done i freaking love
it my biggest problem is every book i
read evan i listen
i i have such a hard time reading i
still have dyslexia
it still doesn't stick so it's taking me
longer but when i actually read a book
it sticks so i highly recommend it and
uh
it's just you it's like it's it's having
a 200 page conversation with you which
is
which is always cool cool man appreciate
it well we also i also have an audiobook
version i
read it myself so there's always oh dude
please send that to me
rule number three rehearse to overcome
with brendan burchard
so if you're trying to figure out why
you're unhappy
start with what routines you continually
doing that are negative
and stick around because in there is a
way to get some more happiness back
it's right there and all we have to do
is make sure first we're aware of them
and then once we're aware of them we
decide we're going to break them
we're going to find a payoff that's
above those
payoffs and it's a very simple thing to
do i'm going to ask you to do one
thing and it's so easy whatever your bad
habit is
all i want you to do is rehearse
overcoming that bad habit rehearse it
because see what we think is that one
day we're just gonna break our bad
habits and it's gonna be instantaneous
and easy
the thing is we have to practice
overcoming a bad habit
to be able to do it in real life so
here's what i mean
what i'd love you to do if your your bad
habit is you just pacify yourself with
food
when you're uncomfortable or unsure what
i love you to do
is not do what everyone else says get
rid of all that food because that
all that food and you know if there's
food around you you're just going to be
fat
right it's like well it's not the food
it's why you're turning to the food
so let's let let's not try and solve the
leave the food and let's practice not
going
to the food let's instead rehearse
okay how do i deal with this emotion
instead of going to the food
what's another way i can have the payoff
of dealing with the emotion without that
thing
that's the bad habit the food as an
example now what i want you to do is
don't wait until next time you're angry
or hurt
or upset to go to the food instead
stand there looking at the food say okay
when was the last time i was really
angry
upset emotional unsure insecure
and i went to that bag of potato chips
when was that
okay let me remember that what was that
like
now let me rehearse not going to the
food
what else could i do what routine or
behavior could i do
instead of the going to the food okay
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
open up my journal right next
right next to that dang bag of chips i'm
gonna open up that journal
i'm gonna look at the chips i'm gonna
open the journal not the chips
open journal not chips open journal not
chips open journal
not chips and i'm gonna write down why
am i
upset if my highest self
was in this situation right now what
would he or she do let me ask you that
question again
if my highest self was in this situation
right now what would he or she
do and i want you to literally write
that out
so what happens with habits is there's a
cue
something negative happens our response
or our routine
is also negative but it feels like it's
paying us off
and then we feel horrible for ourselves
so that middle thing
here's what you do the cue still happens
the cues
my friends are always going to happen
they're always
if stress or drama from another person
drives you in a bad habit i'm
going to tell you there's always going
to be stress and drama from other people
if feeling insecure or unsure always
drives that bad habit
guess what there's always going to be
times in your life you're going to feel
insecure
and unsure the cues my friend are not
going to change
they're always going to be there so your
job
is instead of running that routine of
that bad habit
is identify what you're trying to do am
i trying to protect myself right now
am i trying to pacify myself am i trying
to placate her am i trying to prove
myself
and instead just ask a simple question
what would my highest self do in the
situation
you're not going to win every time
you're just not sometimes
you're gonna have the intention to do
the new positive thing but you do the
old negative thing and i'm here
to tell you that's okay rule number four
have a fresh perspective with john
maxwell let's talk about the word
fresh whenever you go into a restaurant
there's an assumption that the food is
fresh
i mean you certainly wouldn't go into a
restaurant and say what's special and
they say
wow you know fish is you know you can
get fish for two dollars a day well
that's really cheap well yeah we've
had around here for about two weeks you
know oh my gosh we've got a bargain
price on things that are
rotten and stale and not fresh any
longer well you won't get out of that
restaurant so quickly say
what am i doing in a restaurant that
doesn't have fresh food
let me ask you another question what are
you doing with friends that don't have
any fresh thoughts
i mean aren't you tired of being around
people that
basically nothing's changing in their
life that basically what they're doing
today and saying today they could have
done
and said six months ago i mean i've been
away from people
seen them maybe years later sat down
with him at lunch and within five
minutes i thought to myself wow they
ain't moved
they're still right where they were
growth is the greatest prohibitor
of staleness if you want to be fresh
you keep learning and you keep growing
there is nothing that just
absolutely solves the appetite problem
like being around a person that can give
you fresh thoughts fresh
ideas fresh thinking a fresh way to look
in a fresh perspective
i want to sit at the feet of people
that are fresh current learning
growing that's where i want to be
don't want to be around that stale stuff
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is quit junky thoughts with j shetty
junk food junk thoughts and junk
behavior are weighing us down
if i'm giving myself a steady diet of
refined sugar
and processed food if that's what i'm
ingesting i'm going to be tired and
cranky
i'm awake i'm awake but if i eat lots of
fresh produce if i'm consuming things
that are more positive
i'm going to feel energized i'll feel
more motivated my mood will be better
and my thoughts will be clearer and that
makes it easier to make healthy
decisions
it's self-perpetuating have you ever
found it when you're tired you eat worse
when you eat worse you're more tired if
our daily diet is made up of judgment
and anger we're going to feel terrible
we won't be as creative and we won't
feel inspired
studies even show we won't be as
physically healthy because people who
are mostly negative
get sick more often so here are three
ways to consume less negativity
number one if you're frequently checking
social media news headlines throughout
the day
cut down metrics from dscout say the
heaviest data consumers
touch their smartphones 5427 times a day
now not all news and social media
content is negative but every time we're
in those apps
or looking at those headlines it's
opportunity for negativity from
other sources to creep in and add to our
emotional load
and wear us out check social media for
limited times each day
or delete the apps if you need to and if
you can help it
do not check your phone first thing in
the morning whatever you do in the first
few minutes or first
hour after waking sets the tone for the
rest of your day
if you're getting weighed down first
thing in the morning your day will have
a hard time
improving you'll have to spend a lot of
energy and focus
trying to get out from under that
negativity that's one of the reasons
that instead of checking email
amazon ceo jeff bezos prioritizes
spending time with his kids
in the morning before they start school
he'll also
putter around as he calls it cleaning up
the dishes doing some tidying up so his
brain can use this low focus time
to be more creative the second way to
decrease your negativity consumption
is to look at the people you're
surrounding yourself with list out the
five people you communicate with the
most
whether friends co-workers or family
which of them
are sources of negativity in your day
consider
how you can either limit your exposure
to those people if that's possible
or change the nature of your
interactions like maybe a co-worker or
friend really tends to complain a lot
rather than getting pulled into
complaining along with them try changing
the subject or putting a positive slant
on it
please change the subject like if
someone is complaining about a co-worker
or public
figure like so and so is just the worst
maybe say something like
you know who i really think is pretty
cool this person and here's why
just shifting the conversation to a more
positive tone in space
can change the whole vibe positive vibes
only now being positive doesn't mean you
have to pretend
everything's sunshine and roses all the
time it's important to feel our feelings
and to be plugged into what's really
going on in the world but you don't want
to intensify negativity or drama for its
own sake
or for your own entertainment there's a
quote i really love that goes
you can't live a positive life with a
negative mind and that's the third way
of decreasing the negativity in your
life
decrease its impact on you by
emphasizing and increasing
the positive things in your life you can
do this in three ways
one through gratitude instead of
checking your phone first thing when you
wake up
list three things you're grateful for do
it again before you sleep at night
number two through meditation
meditate at least 20 minutes a day you
can use visualization chant a mantra or
simply notice your breath
and here's a huge one number three
through service service boosts your
self-esteem
and your self-worth and service and
gratitude are like
armor that protects you from negativity
identify
one way you can serve others whether
it's tutoring your friend's kid online
for 30 minutes a week
walking an elderly neighbor's dog or
volunteering at a local food bank
those are three powerful ways to lighten
the load of negativity in your life
so you can beat the blues and get into
living a life
filled with meaning power and purpose
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you watch a video and you get
motivated
the science says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place
and how you're going to actually take
action on it you jump to 91
chance of following through and when you
have public accountability and you
commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you you have to un-brand yourself from
who you've been
to get to who you want to be a lot of
people may know you for something
right they may know you for something
they know you for being this kind of
person being the person who does xyz but
maybe you don't like that anymore maybe
you don't want to be that person anymore
and it might require you to unbrand
yourself that you are no longer this
person
in order for them to start seeing you as
this new person that you want to be this
is a tangent that just came to mind but
it's why a lot of people
uh kids have a hard time influencing
their parents
even as adults you know as you as you
are an adult as you grow up and become
an adult you realize
oh your parents didn't actually have
everything figured out they're not the
superheroes you thought they were they
loved you
but a lot of times they're just doing
the best that they could
but most parents do not want to listen
to their kids for advice for what to do
next
because you've been branded as
the kid not as the person who gives
advice
that's why they don't listen to you it's
why it's really hard to influence your
siblings too because
especially if you're the younger sibling
you've been branded as the little
brother the little daughter
or the little little sister you're not
the one that they listen to for advice
you have to unbrand yourself from that
so when i was talking to matthew
about this on on my interview we'll link
that up at the end of this video
he talked about this long unbranding
phase that he went through
where he stopped doing romantic comedies
where he got offered millions and
millions and millions of dollars to keep
doing romantic comedies but he just
didn't want to be that guy anymore he
did not want to be that guy anymore
and so he turned down every single movie
deal
for 20 months for 20 months
considered retiring considered like
acting isn't for him anymore he's
making you know millions of dollars
doing romantic comedies and just
was tired of it not going to do it
anymore and we'd go back and be a
teacher
that was his backup plan
until things changed he successfully
lost the branding as the romantic comedy
guy and he started getting other
opportunities
and i think it starts as a self-identity
thing
who are you do you believe that you're
still the son
do you believe that you're still just
the brother do you believe that you're
still
just xyz of who you used to be and maybe
that was an identity that was given to
you not one that you have ever even
chose for yourself
it starts with the personal unbranding
[Music]
so for me i used to have a website
people knew me from my website
i had a website i was i was heavily into
seo
search engine optimization we had a
hundred thousand plus pages of content i
had
uh thousands i don't know how many
thousands six thousand eight thousand
something like that people writing for
my website i was i was really good at
getting articles to rank
and i was telling my story and famous
stories
and i just got tired of it i don't know
it just seemed to be a publishing game
there seemed to be less heart in the
content we're making
and just seemed to be about ranking
content as opposed to actually doing
something
so i i got a little bored of that and i
started experimenting with youtube
that's the start of my youtube career i
mean i just started experimenting
just throwing out some videos they
weren't they weren't fantastic but it
was just an experiment a test
and i liked it so much that i had to
find a way to keep
doing it and i remember the day that i
shut down my website
i i didn't want to sell it because it
was off my name
and i didn't want to sell ivan
carmichael.com
so i decided to close it down and i
shifted my team
the people who are on my team who are
doing the work for me i gave them roles
in the youtube side of my business that
was starting to take off so nobody
you know got laid off or fired they can
keep working for me in a new capacity
and it took a while for the people who
were successful authors some of the
authors on my site had had posted
hundreds of articles i was driving a lot
of business for them
and we shifted it it wasn't just like a
a shutdown right away but we we phased
in maybe it took a
couple of months for the whole thing to
happen and
i was known as the article guy
it's funny because it's been it's been
over 10 years since that
and now i'm known as the youtube guy or
the believe guy
i actually like believe better because
believe could be anything youtube is too
specific to just one platform but
being known as the believe guy now
there's this great video where grant
cardone
on his christmas uh christmas day he's
filming christmas days
he's doing an ig story of him opening up
or his daughter opening up a present or
something or they walked into a hotel
room or forget what it was but
there was believe there and he said
believe you see that evan carmichael
believe
and he tagged me in the story it's like
yeah i i'm i'm definitely down with
being known as the believe guy
but that became a conscious unbranding
rebranding
phase where i don't want to just be the
article guy i don't want to be known as
the guy who can get your
content ranked in seo and it's funny now
every now and then i connect with an old
author like i connect with somebody who
was on my site who who knew me
back in those days it's like yeah i used
to post
content on your art on on your website i
wrote articles for your website
that was fun and it's like yeah that was
such a long time ago
i don't really think about those days
much anymore
it's how quickly i've unbranded myself
from my own identity
[Music]
if you want to learn to build habits
that last check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there whenever i try to change
anything my number one rule is
100 days or i don't even start
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car